sur le monde est pour
où on l'a fait dans street gears baudets
célèbre high tech salut ça je te
remercie d'avoir accepté ma proposition
d'entretien j'allais dire mon invitation
et vu qu'on est chez toi pas tarder en
dire autant mycroft à vue fut moitié
hospitaliers comme monde à la maison
mais mr dedans avec un ça correspond
assez bien cap ça commence comme
cavernes eh bah ouais ça y est vous
commencent et donc on est la formation
lubrifiants alors avant de commencer
parce que je sens qu'on va rentrer assez
rapidement dans le dur est ce que tu
pourrais te présenter rapidement pour
ceux qui ne connaîtraient pas et vous
dire pourquoi nous sommes ici
aujourd'hui
je m'appelle wojtek j'étais rappeur
j'étais parce que c'est un petit peu
derrière moi maintenant même si j'ai
quelques petits projets en cours mais
bon bref je me définirais pas comme ça
j'aime me définir comme un poète
aujourd'hui je pense que j'assume j'ai
passé les 40 ans j'estime beaucoup plus
de choses
voilà j'espère être un poète tu as
grosso modo on est là parce que j'ai pas
su dire non parce que tu es dumas voir à
l'affect à un moment à l'autre dans nos
échanges comme la vérité c'est qu'un
jour je t'ai laissé un message sur intel
à l improvisation instagram que tu a
repéré mon commentaire et que tu as
réagi donc j'ai compris que tu me
connaissait et qu'on s'est dit ce serait
intéressant car les filous d'accès
savent absolument se sont alors pour
ceux qui ne te connaîtraient pas on te
connaît surtout pour les rap contenders
qui sont les hommes voilà qui sont des
compétitions de clash de battle entre
rappeurs et toi tu es connu comme étant
le grand champion des rap contenders
comment tu t'es retrouvé à participer à
cette compétition qu'est ce qui a fait
que c'est un univers dans lequel tu t es
pas nous imposer bajra peu depuis que
j'étais jeune donc voilà plus ou moins
sérieusement et un pote à moi l'unique
donc a été invitée pour participer à la
première édition j'y suis allé avec lui
parce qu'on regardait déjà ce type de
clash on va dire anglophone et au québec
qui s'appelait lourd de le battle le
voilà ben ali des commandes étaient
dedans voilà je l'accompagné j'ai kiffé
l'ambiant je suis parti voir
l'organisateur d'agnès à la fin pour
direct devant d'être qui est ce qu'il
faut il m'a dit on voit moins une petite
vidéo et un son
donc j'ai enregistré 1 son genre dans
les quinze jours j'ai tourné une petite
vidéo je vais envoyer mon pote l'unica
on va dire appuyer ma demande pour dire
est inquiète pas logiquement il va il va
faire un truc bien et donc j'ai fait un
battle qu'ils ont dû s'enfuir et avant
la diffusion parce que j'avais fait de
l'humour un peu borderline tu vois comme
d'hab apprécié le style de la maison et
puis voilà ça m'a permis de me qualifier
entre guillemets pour la grande ligue
pierre lac est devenu rap contenders
quoi même assis à l'époque c'était une
réunion david 50 personnes dans un petit
sous sol parisien quoi et puis voilà
puis de fil en aiguille j'ai perdu le
premier battle j'ai abandonné sur place
face à jazzy bazz et puis enrichi des
deux de ce feedback tu as j'y suis
retournée et puis là-bas la gg succès
j'ai enchaîné les victoires parce que je
pensais que j'avais compris le truc tout
simplement sans aucune prétention donc
ok parce que ce qui ressort dans les
commentaires qui sont faits à propos des
prestations c'est wojtek été fait pour
ça c'est un peu comme si le format de
ces battles et spécialement calibrée
pour ton mode d'expression bah en fait
c'est une discipline on me demande
d'être un peu violent trash ou en fin du
mois en face à porter ses fruits la base
c'était très efficace sur l'instant
parce qu'on a presque un public oued à
rennes qui veut voir du spectacle et du
combat et moi voilà pareil je n'avais
jamais trophée drap parce que j'étais
enfin l époque un an plus jeune j'étais
aurait jeté trash enfin voilà enfin
l'humour que j'ai défendue dans le rap
contenders et mon humour de tous les
jours donc moi je j'essaye de rire de
tout tu vois quand c'est possible et
voilà de la manière la plus violente
comme ça tu vas enfin quand tu commences
à rigoler honteusement déjà au moins tu
tu lâches tu lâches quelque chose sur
donc je pense qu'il ya des vraies vertus
au reer pour le coup enfin l'humour noir
je pense que l'humour noir il a vraiment
quelque chose de ça peut paraître qu'on
va dire pour ceux qui comprennent pas
que parfois l'intention est complètement
inverse au continue tu vois tes l'humour
c'est une balayette si tu as une bonne
blague bassi est embarquée tu embarques
quoi tu vois alors je rebondis par
rapport à ça sur tout à l'heure tu
arrives et file au rap contenders ton
émission
c'est un mix des deux et je pense que
les deux ont des choses à se dire et la
conversation qu'on a qu'on est en train
d'avoir l'illustrent parce que je
m'étais demandé toi au niveau de
l'écriture tu disais tout à l'heure
l'humour noir ça peut avoir des vertus
et est ce que l'écriture aussi peut
avoir des vertus c'est à dire quand tu
extériorise cette violence là est-ce que
ça revient pas à vous et freud parler de
la sublimation des pulsions c'est à dire
une énergie au départ diriger vers la
destruction eh bien on la met au service
de quelque chose qu'on peut appeler une
oeuvre est ce que toi ton écriture elle
est un petit peu dirigé par ce principe
là ou pas du tout
initialement initialement la démarche
n'était pas n'avait pas ses dimensions
ni philosophique ni truc à la base c'est
faux va n'est jamais écrire je suis un
bon gars ne retient savez unit les deux
je vais y aller tu vois voilà les après
effectivement compter au centre de
l'attention parce que voilà l'événement
a pris du succès puis on commence à
voile à faire du buzz et puis tu vois ça
fait quelques millions de vues on
commença de reconnaître enfin bref tu
sens qu'il ya quelque chose des fois tu
es kiki qui change autour de toi tu vois
et là tu dis ouais ok show centre de
beaucoup d'énergie quand même tu vois
alors que à la base c'était pas du tout
mais ça va tu sais c'est un battle par
an donc en fait ça se fait sur le ca
s'est fait sur le tas mais oui après oui
je suppose que oui enfin je veux dire et
j'ai c'est qui ces fraudes qui désole
c'est pas sexuelle est liée à la petite
enfance est fascinant c'est sexuel oui
donc il ya la petite enfance chez freud
mais en gros c'est l'idée que ans chaque
humain il ya une part d'animalité et que
cette part d'animalité ça bien sûr enfin
je veux dire ont exprimé directement
quoi on va pas parce qu'on disait
surtout qu'aujourd'hui où tout est
censurable tu vois mais ça ça va presque
un peu de soi enfin je veux dire c'est
presque acquis que effectivement que ce
soit physiologiquement au quoi enfin
ouais on a une partie instinctive animal
en où tu vois un cerveau reptilien enfin
voilà des réflexes la peur tout ça enfin
c'est très animal tout ça donc ouais il
ya bien sûr cette partie là ben je pense
que ça fait du bien en tout cas bas la
plupart des métallos t'as vu c'est des
mecs ils sont doux comme des agneaux
dans la ville et
les sportifs les combattants de mma
c'est pareil parce qu'effectivement tu
as peut-être l'occasion d'avoir un
terrain de jeu pour assumer l'entièreté
de ta personne et peut être comme
aujourd'hui dans la société qui va
vouloir faire une va occulter tu adores
la violence c'est pas bien tu alors que
la violence et la nature elle tu vois
les bébés chiens qui jouent tous les
tous les garçons presque dans le monde
se bagarre quand ils sont au jeune tu
vois mais si tu leur interdit de se
battre ils ont fui c'est à la fin voilà
ils se tirent dessus toi parce qu'ils
n'ont pas eu l'occasion de régler leurs
comptes à dire même en france dans le
sud la castagne tu as la bagarre c'est
même une tradition tu te rends pas sur
la gueule et après tu vas au bistrot
pour de réconcilier il n'y avait pas
mort d'homme tu vois aujourd'hui voilà
il ya une bagarre mutualisant crie ça
sorte de téléphone la police là
franchement on se branler la nouille
beaucoup quand même là dessus l'analyse
est un petit peu rapport à la violence
non mais enfin je veux dire qu'est ce
que c'est que cette mascarade faut
arrêter tu vois j'ai droit je suis dans
ma cave
dames et oui bien sûr foire était faut
arrêter tu as un faut arrêter ce pas
parce que ton garçon est lancé mais il
s'est battu à l'école que mon dieu c'est
un futur délinquant au contraire t il ya
un moment il s'est pas laissé faire
c'est peut-être ça même à la fin tu vois
ce que je veux dire alors bien sûr faut
cadrer il ya toujours quelqu'un pour
séparer si tu laisses faire en plus tu
as les mecs vont se bat et puis quand il
y en a un qui prend le dessus
naturellement favre n'est pas des
animaux sanguinaire t enfin je veux dire
je connais pas un enfant de 13 ans qui
va s'amuser à manger tue à l'oreille de
tu vois si ça arrive c'est grave dans ce
cas là il y avait un boulot à faire en
amont et personne n'a rien vu tu vois
mes mais ouais on diabolise beaucoup
beaucoup de choses qui sont purement
naturel à la basse cohésion donc
il faut se démerder avec maintenant bon
donc ce n'était pas complètement de la
branlette non plus cette histoire de
fraude non je dis pas que c'est de la
branlette c'est ce que oui bien sûr si
on pousse l'analyse mais si tu me dis
est ce que moi je prête ça non je te dis
ça parce que j'ai la sensation alors il
faudrait que les gens aillent voir un
petit peu ce que tu fais comment tu fais
pour avoir cette sensation là ou pas que
tu penses que tu fais il ya des phrases
dont je ne peux pas croire que tu les ai
écrites et interprétées
sans qu'elles aient une signification
particulière pour toi au niveau
spirituel et moi j'aimerais savoir si
pour toi l'art en général à un sens à
quoi ça sert pourquoi on fait ça toi
pourquoi tu fais ça je crois que les
grecs anciens enfin je crois que c'est
des grecs
qui disait que la perfection c'est le
domaine des dieux et le but de l'art
c'est ici quand même d'atteindre la
perfection alors c'est peut-être mal
résumé mai mais ouais effectivement
enfin je veux dire dès lors où
il ya des poèmes français s'est même pas
ma langue maternelle le français mais
y'a des poèmes français ils sont
tellement beaux ils ont deux siècles ils
sont d'actualité tu vois ce que je veux
dire enfin tu dis qu'on aimait qu'ils
arrivent à un tel degré de ses baux en
fait tu vois c'est donc loin moi c'était
important de d2 de penser intemporel de
penser un peu universel tu as 2 2 je me
suis dit c'est un truc faudrait que ça
vieillissant moment tu vois donc à
peut-être pas au début tu vois mais
c'est vrai qu'avec le temps je vais
peut-être trouvé un certain style une
certaine oraison et tu vois dans le truc
et que c'est clairement pas
puis c'est même pas la plume en fait
hein tu vois pas ce qu'il y'a des plumes
plus technique que moi plus précises
plus fine plus joli plus rap tu vois je
pense que c'est le verbe le verbe
créateur carlo verse opodo c'est pour ça
qu'en par le vert parce que
jean mayer bah je sais pas c'est un truc
un peu mystique en fait le verbe c'est
la capacité magique qu'on les mots de
d'avoir un impact sur la réalité avec le
verbe tu peux faire pleurer quelqu'un tu
peux faire tomber amoureux quelqu'un tu
vois ce que je veux dire si alonso
chez renault alors sirhan ont séduit
roxane sa cousine dont ils abreuvaient
en écrivant les lettres de son
prétendant christian elle tombe amoureux
de celui qui est notre cas janvier à
cyrano sadirac une en bronze de cyrano
par le
mais c'est un peu un cessieu quand même
oui on avait le droit le puck master l
axe mais je pense que c'est ça en fait
tu vois enfin après cc c'est pour ça que
j'aime le côté poète en fait j'ai
compris pourquoi on disait que les
poètes étaient les favoris des dieux tu
vois deux parmi tous les artistes vois
pas ce qu'il y'a une étape en fait un
sculpteur peut sculpter évoquer quelque
chose un peintre peut dire quelque chose
sans le dire le poète il est obligé de
rationaliser ce qu'il ressent et donc
des noix ou tu passes par la phase
intellect pour donner une des bombes a
tu t'éloignes un petit peu tu vois et
c'est pas facile d'être bien inspiré
c'est pour ça qu'en fait on voudrait
toujours tu es on voudrait écrire un
joli poème tous les jours mon n'y arrive
pas donc c'est bien dire qu'il ne s'agit
il ne suffit pas de vouloir tu as il ya
bien quelque chose à un moment fin qui
vient de chuchoter à l'oreille tu vois
il appelait les mus par exemple où
quelque chose en tout cas les
interactions sociales avec les zones
j'en sais rien c'est qu'est-ce que ça
symbolise mai mais on reste en europe
sous le mot inspiration en fait c'est
peut-être quelque chose
inspiration inspiration vient donc tu va
retirer l'air elle qu'est ce qu'il ya
autour de toi tu vas dans tous les cas
enfin le l'artiste de manière générale
est un peu le reflet de ce qui se passe
autour de lui tu vois c'est un peu je
pense comme ça que ça fonctionne tu vois
pour le coup et voilà je pense que enfin
voila je m'étais posé ces questions sur
sur les poètes et pourquoi certains
grands poètes français ont eu un destin
tragique qui aura enfin je veux dire tu
sais pas il y avait et quelque chose qui
m'attirait dans tout ça puis à force de
t'intéresser comme ça et tu vois et
d'être curieux étudierait fin
les les images ont fait ce qu en en fait
vu qu'on fonctionne par représentation
mentale le poète celui qui arrive à
trouver des belles images en fait
arrivera peut-être avoir une plus belle
représentation du monde et si le monde
autour de lui et plus beaux pas
forcément je pense qu'il est bon il y
sont mieux ils sont bientôt bon alors
profitons-en pour parler un peu ton
actualité donc tu n'es pas seulement un
clash heures tu as aussi un homme de
scène s'était déjà créé son propre one
man show est ce que tu peux nous en
parler un seul en scène un salon scène
pour ceux qui connaîtraient pas la
référence salle c'est le cri poussé par
le public lorsque la lave année
particulièrement salée ouais épicéa être
vrai dire c'est généralement ouais donc
j'avais j'avais j'ai écrit un spectacle
qui s'appelle sa mère la plume que
j'avais lancé ben en 2019 je crois et
donc qu'est ce que tu as voulu dire
après ce spectacle est ce que ça
répondait à un besoin d'exprimer quelque
chose est ce que c'est juste la belle a
déjà déjà de ne plus être résumé un
clash heures tu vends parce que les
battles c'est cool je ne crache pas dans
la soupe ça va ça m'a permis d'exister
d'avoir un nom tu vas afin même ça
apporte d'autres projets dans la foulée
tu vois ouais c'est ça des rencontres et
puis de l'affect beaucoup d'affect tu as
et ce qui est cool comme les battles son
bar ans que j'ai fait rigoler les jambes
quand ils me voient ils ont un sourire
donc c'est toujours super agréable tu
vois moi qui étais un peu misanthrope
jusqu'à 30 ans le tueur aux fumades
névrose à l'été tels que j'ai réussi à
recréer un monde autour de moi qui
n'existe que de mon point de vue tu vois
c'est à dire que les gens sont plus
gentils avec moi mais je pense qu'ils en
même temps j'en avais besoin pour être
capable de supporter le monde tu vois ce
que je veux dire ok c je sais pas c'est
bizarre mais je sais que bah ouais tu
vois quand quelqu'un me reconnais bon en
fait et ben bass est différent tu vois
mais c'est pas tout le monde donc voilà
comment je le vois mais je pense que
encore une fois c'est une espèce de chez
pas c'est chou comme moi si tu devais
résumer un peu les grands lignes de ton
spectacle on en a parlé un petit peu
auront-elles c'est quoi les axes les
points cardinaux
c'est allez on va dire
ma poésie
au kop
moore philosophie dans cet ordre là je
pas vraiment vrai qu'un gros un peu
organique pas vraiment linéaire tu as
enfin si les captifs du conducteur est
toujours le fil d'ariane dans le
labyrinthe que même toi mais mais voilà
dans gaza est ce que tu veux dire que
tout ça va ensemble et doit pas être
séparés
bah ouais enfin oui méchant la
spécialisation enfin isolé
diabolo en grec c'est ce qui sépare ce
qu'ils disent tu vas symbole c'est ce
qui rassemble donc le but c'est sympa
c'est de trouver sa mère à la grosse
prime symbolise bien tu as voulu dire
ouais ce rapport l'un parce
qu'effectivement écrire beaucoup emmène
sur des réflexions que tu aurais pas eu
l'occasion si jamais tu étais même à la
pêche aura l'occasion de philosopher
mais tu serais pas dans tu vas enfin je
pense que le cheminement que j'ai fait
aujourd'hui il est assez particulier tu
vois pas ce que voilà je suis fâché pas
voilà je sais que j'ai ma petite
singularité là dedans que j'ai fait ma
propre synthèse et du coup comme je te
dis je vis ma propre vision du moungo et
la plume je passe je la fais exprès même
si ça veut peut-être dire de venir faire
exprès mais métaphoriquement c'est
l'esprit welch et les égyptiens au pesto
on pèse ton âme si jamais elle est plus
lourde qu'une bible de match tu vas en
enfer
tu finis dans la grande dévoreuse et
tourne à ton âme et d'année et la plume
c'est pas envie non sans doute pas envie
ouais mais il ya un parcours de
purification entre la mort physique et
là je parle avec un mec à la salle de
sport l'âme n'existent pas
d'ailleurs je vais te poser la question
comment tu écris d'or tu disais que le
fait que parfois les idées elle arrive
en toi davantage que tu ne vas à elle
qu'est ce qui se passe au moment où tu
écris est ce que tu as la sensation
d'être être touché par quelque chose de
supérieur est ce que ça bah non en fait
c'est maija se pose la même question que
explique mans le processus de quand tu
as une idée ben justement ben je peux
t'en parler j'en ai parlé récemment la
sur ma chaîne c'est que j'ai
l'impression que c'est les idées qui
viennent on voit que j'en suis un peu le
réceptacle et que mon seul travail c'est
de les mettre en forme c'est de produire
de l'est j pour les mettre en forme mais
à la base je suis pas responsable de ce
qui me traversent non je suis le camp
bah je sais pas enfin ouais il ya un
côté invisible et mystique comme je le
disais déjà tout à l'heure dans la vie
tu vois donc dans tous les cas si on est
dans la fin si on reste dans le déni à
un moment je suis désolé c'est ça va ça
va casser quelque chose qui va casser tu
vois si on veut que ça passe faut aussi
avoir je pense une lecture de toutes ses
dimensions un petit peu invisible donc
on peut l'appeler spirituel ou quoi mais
enfin de même le mot spirituel c'est
compliqué quand il s'agit pas de en fait
si c'est important de croire en quelque
chose tu vois c'est important d'avoir
une belle représentation du monde tu as
moi je pense que me dire que je suis le
petit fils d'un singe hasardeuse
sodomites tu vas voir c'est pas beau si
c'est pas beau ça donne pas envie en
fait je veux dire dans ces cas là ouais
c'est la porte ouverte soit open bar non
peux tu étais on n'est que des animaux
tu vois ce que je veux dire et même à ce
jour on peut pas prouver que ça s'est
passé comme ça tu vas donc j'ai envie de
croire qu'ils aient quelque chose de un
peu plus beau un peu plus uniques un peu
plus magique un peu plus chez pas moi
donc c'est sympa mais des fois j'ai du
mal à y croire franchement tu vois quand
je vois ce qui se passe autour de nous
je mouillais ça y est franchement allez
vas-y ces bons envoyés le raz-de-marée
je pense qu'on l'a bien cherché des
choses que je viens j'ai parfois du mal
à me dire bon tu vois allant bien sûr il
reste la beauté reste de l'amour mais
des fois tu dis
c'est chaud toi enfin quand tu vois là
et comme j quand tu vois le chantier
pour sauver le monde mais quand tu vois
la main d'oeuvre disponible tu sais que
ça va prendre du retard quand tu vois
que tu es
considéré que l'espèce humaine n'est pas
forcément la meilleure chose que la
nature est forte franchement je pense qu
on a l'équivalent du corps humain
facture elle d'humanité est à la terre
ce que la tumeur est encore en cours tu
vois on peut a dit pénale malin c'est à
dire qu'il ya une certaine humanité qui
a su s'adapter à son environnement la
masoni le pôle nord le désert et y
survivre et puis à celui qui arrive et
qui détournent le cours d'eau pour avoir
l'eau potable tue l eau courante quoi
donc cette méthode la fin voilà tu vois
alors bien sûr on est pris au piège et
un toit mais les hydrocarbures les
fossiles c'est comme si qu'on est en
train de drainer tu vois ce que je veux
dire je me dis si l'humanité était sur
moi ils seront encadrés des thés mais tu
es ab minéraux mais ça mais machin mes
trucs et donc forcément tu sais que ça
peut pas ça peut plus aller comme ça
mais maintenant tu étais pris au piège
que enfin le principe du virus c'est de
s'alimenter de son environnement n'avait
on parle pas de virus tenue
et ça va déraper sa version est la seule
chaîne où on parle pas d'actualité ici
et d'ailleurs c'est le l'anagramme
phonétique de virus et survie et tu
parles de la ressource comme quelque
chose qui nous motive fondamentalement
alors est ce qu'on peut en vouloir à
l'être humain de lutter pour sa survie
non mais j'ai l'impression qu'il ya un
moment les méchants ont gagné en fait si
tu as un c'est à dire que certes on est
le fruit paraît-il puisse a besoin un
peu dans les côtés d'une longue
succession de mâles alphas guerrier tu
vois il fallait être fort grimper aux
arbres courir se battre et robuste donc
si on en croit la version officielle ça
fait des dizaines des centaines de
milliers d'années qu'on accumule des
jeunes comme ça tu vois hélas en
quelques siècles il faut que d'un seul
coup on devienne complètement
radicalement différent tu vois mais du
coup je me dis aujourd'hui même côté
chétif petit tu as accès à beaucoup de
choses dans la société moderne qui
n'avaient pas accès quand c'était juste
la force qui mesurait la valeur d'un
individu tu vois donc je pense que ça
crée un chaos on est beaucoup parce que
la science certes même si a fait
énormément de progrès ma mère nature
n'est pas renier pas beaucoup d'enfants
initialement tu vois ce que je veux dire
pour des balades guidées malformations à
la naissance et des prématurés et où tu
vois nous tout ce que berné tirs
n'auraient pas épargné on les a faits
vivre donc des fois c'est un peu cruel
de le dire
ou est ce que vraiment ces gens là sont
aptes à traverser le monde tu vois ce
que l'offensé on est beaucoup on est
beaucoup trop parce que justement de
confort est justement ce cette faible
mortalité au final fait qu'on s'est
répandue peut-être beaucoup trop vite tu
vas enfin je parle principalement de
l'intérêt qu'il ya à l'occident aussi qu
un truc qui que disait rousseau à son
époque il n'est pas comparable avec la
nôtre mais qui avec 9 anticipé c'est que
la préservation de l' de la vie par la
technique et les arts les arts c'est à
dire les savoirs s'est accompagnée d'un
amollissement la ramollissement des
comportements ce qui fait que c'est pas
forcément le plus fort qui survit ça
peut être parfois le plus fourbe le plus
malin le plus astucieux balle surtout
depuis ben cavell quoi voilà le bain je
suis là c'est justement je vois sa
pensée il tua et ouais effectivement on
sait que à la guerre ce sont les plus
courageux qui tombe c'est à dire ceux
qui vont nous contacter finalement
l'évolution tel qu'on l'entend n'est pas
synonyme de progrès l'évolution peut se
faire dans un sens ou dans un autre et
de ce point de vue là je suis pas sûr
qu'on soit forcément à la pointe de
l'évolution tel que l'entend de nos
jours est ce que la modernité est un
progrès pas toujours tu vois ce que je
crois que c'est renault rené guénon qui
renversa effectivement tout ce qui est
moderne n'est pas forcément un véritable
progrès tu vois il ya certaines choses
dans la tradition tu vois où flotte un
peu conservateur sur certains détails tu
vois pas ce qu on a beau dire attention
c'est ce que je disais la sur les
enfants - ma fille née prématurée tu
vois et sans la science sans la
technologie je sais qu'elle n'aurait pas
survécu donc je me suis posé cette
question vraiment mes skis et maître de
tahiti si à un moment les circonstances
avaient décidé que je ne devais pas tu
vois c'est dur de se poser sa com qu'il
fasse et et tu as mais donc tu pense
aussi au fait que la vie n'est pas qu'un
cadeau
dont la vie c'est une épreuve c'est un
test là franchement well as les
spiritualités les philosophies enfin
ouais il ya quelque chose d'autre du
rhin on a accès qu'à une facettes de la
réalité de ces meubles et couleurs dans
le spectre voit la terre on voit l'arc
en ciel du rouge au violet après c'est
infrarouges et ultraviolets tu vois plus
rien tu vois donc on a vraiment on est
programmé pour avoir accès à ça et puis
tout le reste nous échappe un petit peu
et que le reste des prétoires où est-ce
qu'on laisse qu'on invente ce qu'on le
cherche je pense qu'on le pense il
résonance je pense la pensée créatrice à
voulait rien dire quand j'étais plus
jeune mais plus je vieillis plus je me
rends compte de ce que ça veut dire en
fait y'a vraiment les mêmes qu'on
parlait tout à l'heure vite et enfin le
temps même la perception qu'on puisse
être content qu'on ait du temps tu vois
comme si que c'était une frise
chronologique linéaire qui avançait de
gauche à droite alors que on se rend
bien compte que voyez quelque chose de
plus ouroux mauresque tu vois des fois
dans le temps parce que cyclique bas
parce que les vaches s'est pas tu vas
cesser d'être un chien après libre à
chacun de faire son propre cheminement
parce qu'elle a eu faim peut se perdre
avant de commencer à arriver sur ce
genre de petites révélations mais là tu
es au coeur de la jungle ou de
l'obscurité à moi qui dispute un
maintien mais voilà il ya quelque chose
de très très la vie c'est magique la vie
c'est mystique celui qui voit pas la
dimension mystique de la vie qui se
contentent de l'apparence du
matérialisme il est cuit un espace
accueil bar est clairement il part à
côté passé à côté d'une grande partie de
l'espérance sachant qu'on accès qu'à une
partie déjà c'est on va pas se tuer donc
sept autres partis mettront qu'on essaye
de penser est ce que toi tu la pensée et
qu'est-ce que tu mets autour donc de ce
ce spectre de perception auquel on est
limité d'après toi ya quelque chose
d'autre ben il ya tout le reste en fait
il ya tout le reste il ya tout le reste
est à dire que nous on a accès des
amplis psychologiquement le confiant ça
représente 10% de notre personne fin de
ce qu'on est et que l'inconscient
belgique 90 % de notre comportement je
pense que dans cette vie en fait on est
dans la conscience de la vie donc on a
accès à 10% par latine c'est aussi le
pourcentage du cerveau qu'on utilise
enfin bref tu vois mais je pense qu'on a
vraiment accès à une infime parcelle de
ce qui est véritablement talent voit pas
la wi fi on voit pas les ondes fm et
pourtant en ce moment il ya quinze
chansons qui nous traversent mais quand
même même si la science observe et
reproduit par expérience
ça n'expliquera jamais la programmation
en fait tu vois ce que je veux dire
c'est bien beau de dire ok la théorie
des cordes en physique quantique ou tu
vois les électrons tourne autour de
l'atome etc d'accord mais en fait mais
enfin je veux dire ok on observe mais ça
ça explique rien non tu as et avec rick
nous après la philosophie en fait la
philosophie je pense doit avancer de
pair avec la chance parce que quand tu
es confronté à ça tu es bien obligé en
fait d'essayer de trouver à travers des
images et une représentation pour tenter
de comprendre ce qui est en train de
voir en fait et quelles implications
cela peut avoir à une échelle plus
grande tu vois
mais ouais enfin dû dire oui moi je suis
de ces chercheurs là c'est à dire que je
sais qu'il ya des gens qui ne se pose
pas de question qu'ils se sont bien tu
vois enfin voilà ils ont leur quête là
il faut absolument qu'ils cherchent à
expliquer un phénomène mais sans se
poser la question d'une qu'est ce qui
fait que ce phénomène a une explication
quant à newton définit la loi de la
gravitation lui il a l'impression
d'identifier quelque chose de vivant
parce qu'il décrypte quelque chose qui
échappe à toute tentative d'explication
rationnelle c'est à dire l'idée que un
ordre nous gouvernent d'ailleurs may and
go away mais même si les mathématiques
autour de nous enfin il ya un ordre un
tu vois comme on disait alors les
oiseaux ne migrent pas deux mois al
avance une fleur ne va pas éclore trois
mois en retard enfin je veux dire il ya
un ordre les marais et tu vois et elles
vont elles viennent enfin tout et tout
écart et tu vois à part nous tu voyais
avec nous on est là on désobéit
parlons-en il ya un épisode de la bible
que tout le monde connaît le péché
d'adam et eve ouais et eve tenté par le
serpent goût du fruit de la connaissance
du bien et du mal et à partir de là
c'est là la déchéance littéralement adam
lève sont expulsés et ils sont voués
condamné à expérimenter les lois de la
matière c'est à dire de la souffrance et
du travail pour expier leurs crimes
leurs péchés et j'en avais parlé dans un
épisode à savoir est-ce que adam et eve
sont par les inventeurs de la liberté du
libre arbitre qui définit l'être humain
qui est en même temps sa grandeur mais
en même temps aussi la cause de sa
déchéance c'est à dire que la liberté
c'est ce qui nous permet de faire
n'importe quoi je suis pas franchement
c'est un épisode sur lequel je me suis
beaucoup pris la tête - adam eve parce
que déjà dans ff n'est pas le premier
homme à la première femme la première
femme elle s'appelle liszt tu as elle a
été boycottée tu vois de de même de
l'inconscient collectif tu vois parce
qu'elle avait refusé de se soumettre a
donc peut-être pendant l'amour tu vois
et après quand dieu lui a dit vas y
jouent le jeu tu vois où je sais pas
comment je sais pas et tu vas forcément
maladie maintenant je veux pas si je
suis son égal je me soumettrai pas tu
vas et du coup elle a été diabolisé pour
ça je pense que c'est la version courte
et du coût élevé et là on nous présente
eve la première femme comme étant une
excroissance ouais tu vois comme étant
dépendante de la femme donc bon à très
longtemps justement mon premier texte un
peu comique que j'ai testé justement sur
des trucs un peu humoristique c'était à
15 ans étaient justement sur adam et eve
en fait ont grosso modo on a franchement
on n'a jamais eu besoin des femmes pour
[ __ ] la merde c'est souvent peut-être
pour s'attirer l'attention d'une femme
ou pour être cetera mais je trouve que
c'est facile de dire ouais cf qui
voulait la pomme on y allait déjà la
pomme à l'époque dans le moyen-orient ça
n'existait pas donc le fruit de la
connaissance ne peut pas être la pomme
peut-être une grenade ce qu'est la
grenade en plus et symbolise bien
l'unité avec toutes ces petites tu vas
cellule divisibles à l'intérieur donc
déjà dans eve et puis même tu vois un
moment ils mangent le en fait voilà déjà
l'arbre avec le serpent ça me fait un
peu penser aux serpents du kundalini tu
vois qui monte ça me fait penser un peu
aux cailles du c'est forcément d'hermès
tu as le cerveau reptilien tu vois le
comédien l'instinct gardien de la
connaissance tueur grosso modo la
connaissance de dieu celle qui permet de
différencier le bien et du mal tu as
donc adam et eve part et ils veulent
connaître la différence entre le bien et
le mal et donc ils mangent la paix mais
pillay prennent conscience de leur
nudité est ce que c'est pas aussi une
métaphore pour parler du passage de
sapiens sapiens sapiens l'homme qui sait
à qui exactement tu en as marre ils ont
pris conscience de leur nudité c'est le
plaid sacsam et abolition la chute sur
terre même ça correspond peut-être à la
naissance parce qu'au début le jardin
d'éden en fait une fait qu'un avec ta
mère tu faire l'inité tu vois exactement
et d'un seul coup bing tu plonges rendre
dans l'enfer de la drire tu as tu tombe
littéralement donc les enfers et eni
toujours représenté en mais c'est vrai
qu'on est jeté dans un univers hostile
où il fait froid où les gens font du
bruit ils rient alors qu'on souffre donc
c'est quand même l'expérience la plus
traumatisante puisse être deux sur soi
et donc pour en revenir à adam et eve on
a découvert la dualité c'est à dire le
choix et en choisissant l'interdît ben
on est entré dans la dualité et la
dualité c'est aussi la dissociation donc
la conscience de soi on prend conscience
qu'on a la possibilité 2 même si cette
possibilité est considéré comme défendu
et à partir de là on devient responsable
c'est à dire ok tu as choisi ça mais par
contre il va devoir en assumer la
responsabilité
donc tu as choisi de croquer le fruit
maintenant tu va expérimenter les lois
de la matière ça va faire mal par là où
ça va passer mais par contre en retrait
annoncé c'est pour ça qu'on a un peu le
fruit défendu seul fruit interdit s'est
il défendu il ya les vacances on va
falloir se battre en fait tu vois il ya
un moment il va falloir que tu te battre
parce qu'effectivement mais bmc matrix
tu vois est ce que tu vas continuer à
rester dans un mensonge rassurant est ce
que tu vas opté pour la vérité qui
dérange équité prouve tu vois ressemble
de l'effort ou le confort tu vois elle
est là en fait la dualité tu as grosso
modo est ce que tu vas à l'image des
alchimistes tu vas travailler sur la
matière pour la purifier pour faire du
pont de l'or tu vois où est-ce qu au
contraire bon tu vas te contenter de
manger un steak au restaurant et puis te
dire que ça va aller tu vois mais bon
après je persuadé que même les problèmes
de santé
sais pas j'ai vu assez de gens vieillir
et mourir en franchement enfin voila je
veux rendre compte que souvent enfin la
mort les circonstances la maladie qui en
portent les gens en fait aidé
bizarrement associés en fait à leurs
travers tu vois ce que je veux dire
enfin je sais pas c'est un petit sondage
personnel comme ça à quoi tu vois le
père d'un ami qui est un homme
d'affaires de ouf tu vois qu'ils étaient
jamais là et ces tueries qui a fait de
l'oseille bon fait il est mort en mode
avec sa tête qui a défailli alzheimer il
rappelait plus ils reconnaissaient plus
personne lettre cette erreur tu vois
un autre grand père qui lui est devenu
aveugle alors que voilà il a été dans le
déni toute sa life tu vois ce que je
veux dire il est pas mort pour le coup
mais il est devenu aveugle exactement
enfin franchement j'y crois aujourd'hui
j'ai vu assez ça enfin
même demandé au sein de même fratrie tu
sais tu développes pas les mêmes mode tu
vois les mêmes mots alors que si tout
est héréditaire pas pourquoi ça se
répercute pas donc je pense qu'il veut
tous qu'ils ne s'expriment pas
tu vois avant tout ce qui n'est pas
clarifiée tout ce qui n'est pas guéri
pas forcément va se loger quelques pas
puis clame allons genou il a du mal à
s'agenouiller sait qu'il a du mal avec
l'autorité ou la soumission tu vois
qu'elle soit spirituel hiérarchique
amoureuse et tu vois la soumission
peut-être que tu as l'impression qu'ils
te mettre à genou et ben c'est un acte
de soumission dévalorisant alors que non
des fontes mettant à genoux tu valorise
le trait tu fait fureur ouais donc je
pense que c'est ça le problème peut-être
tu vois moi j'imagine parachute et
la souplesse les gens j'ai mal au dos
parce qu'ils en ont plein le dos il
n'arrive pas à régler leurs problèmes
ils en ont trop où tu vas et tu sais
quoi
donc je pense qu'il ya plein de même
dans les mots je suis sûr qu'il ya plein
d'expressions comme ça qui nous donne
des indices sur le fait que fait pour
aller bien ma foi et enfin bref au faut
travailler tout ce à quoi font en tout
cas on nous a empêchés de la laïcité je
pense qu'elle nous a enlevé ce trépied
effectivement comme je disais alors moi
je me vois comme un esprit qu'est le
siège de ma pensée de mes idées de ma
maison un corps qui ne siège de mes
besoins de mes pulsions physiologique tu
as mangé chier baiser tout ça est une
âme qui est le siège social de mes
émotions et de ce que je ressens et pour
le coup il ya vraiment un principe
masculin je dois mon esprit es tu vois
comme un principe actif est là mais elle
est réceptive tu vois une scène de
violence étaient touchés tu vois la
beauté d'un paysage tu vois un cul tu
vois tu as un verre tu vois qui se
remplit qui prend la couleur toi les
émotions c'est de l'eau en fait tu m'as
un sachet de thé dedans tu vois ça ça
fuse situe à grosso modo ça prend la
couleur et tu as parlé des émaux et de
ceux qui s'expriment à travers les mots
je pense que tu es pas sans savoir que
certaines théories en psychanalyse
disent que le le verbe le langage pour
le coup on y revient c'est un mode
d'expression de l'inconscient c'est ce
qu'on appelle mon les lapsus
la langue des oiseaux jeunes à dire le
fait j'avais cette idée que derrière le
langage il ya une signification
secondaire qui est parfois peut-être la
plus essentielle qui s'exprime il ya
plusieurs manières des fois d'entendre
certains mots ou certaines phrases
est-ce que ça c'est quelque chose dans
lequel tu crois
parce que forcément les érudits ce qui
crée les beaux un moment c'est des mecs
qui parlait grec le latin il ya un
moment les bons les inventer tu vois
même quand on est passé du vieux
français aux nouveaux français on va
dire mais il ya un moment c'était des
érudits qui se réunissaient et le savoir
il a toujours été et voilà dix tiller
avec précaution et tu vois donc on va te
donner des mets pour tout le monde mais
avec les indices dedans pour celui qui
cherche pour le rapprocher tu vois de
son étymologie de tout ça de tout ça
donc bien sûr que je crois tu as des
mots comme trépassé ils sont super
intéressant et tu vois ce bon moyen âge
et qui parle de la mort baïla la motion
trip tu as donc c'est à dire qu'il ya
pas qu une seulement il ya 3 tu vois il
ya trois mois trois passages et comme
dirait patrick de richesse qu'est ce
qu'un passage si ce n'est qu'un si ce
n'est à pas prudents doigts pour le coup
donc même le passage tu peux le
décrypter en peinture donc ouais non moi
je crois grave et normand d'ailleurs
enfin ça m'a permis moi de comprendre
tiens ouais ouais ça m'a permis d'être
en paix avec certains trucs tu as grosso
modo je parle dans mon spectacle aussi
bas 2-2 de la langue des oiseaux un
petit peu tu as 2 comment à travers ben
voilà un sens caché dans le mot en fait
toi comme qui est à l'heure je parle
ainsi pu de keanu tonnes ou quoi
en fait là le tout est déjà autour de
nous il suffit en fait d'y avoir accès
tu vois pythagore n'a pas inventé le
théorème de pythagore tu as mais il l'a
captée en fait ils acquièrent [ __ ]
truc de ouf voix mais c'est pas lui qui
a créé cette règle là il a juste vu en
fait sur
le club à il ya plus qu'à chercher en
fait autour de louis tu vas mais tout
est déjà là on fait quoi c'est pour ça
que je crois pas en l'existence par
contre d'un dieu qui intervient chaque
seconde tu vois si dieu est un créateur
comme n'importe quel créateur il a fini
son oeuvre il n'est pas ça la suivante
située à ce que je veux dire ou alors il
en déprime il est dans sa phase éponge
il absorbe et oui tu vois pas ce qu'on
l'a peut-être pas bougé que tu fais
peut-être d'un sénat il a fait une expo
avec nous à vis à vis très franchement
on peut rater sur ce coup là tu as donc
va savoir tu vois je pense pas que s'il
ya un seul créateur de tout l'univers
tu vois je pense qu'il a autre chose à
[ __ ] que de s'occuper de nous c'est
très très arrogant en fait si tu ne
trouves pas genre l'univers et je sais
pas aimer ya grand etc l'univers est
super g et nous gens qui nous regardent
nous il est là et c'est donc tu vois ce
que je veux dire c'est non on pourrait
dire que dans cette vision il a mis en
nous la possibilité de savoir qu'il
existe et donc ça fait de nous quelque
part des êtres qui ont une
responsabilité à savoir de diffuser
cette médias pas il n'y a pas une un
courant philosophique qui dit que aussi
l'homme a créé dieu pour essayer de
trouver un sens ce qui vivait chez cette
réduction mis à dire que ont créé des
idoles parce qu'on a peur d'affronter la
vie dans dans ce qu'elle peut aussi
avoir d' absurde et d'impénétrables à la
raison mais en fait il ya bien en tout
cas un point commun toutes les humanités
ou importe peu importe leur emplacement
géographique etc etc c'est qu'ils ont
tout développer un imaginaire elles ont
toutes choisi de croire en au final on
s'en bat les couilles de quoi tu kroll
l'important c'est d'avoir au moins des
fondations psychologique ou spirituelle
assez solide dans sur lesquels tu puisse
bâtir d'autres idées en fait tu vois
tout simplement mais aujourd'hui on dit
je crois que donc ça implique un certain
doute alors que croire je crois que ça
vient de certitudes c'est je crois en
même ce mot-là a perdu de sa force et de
son sens premier et tu vois on a beau
vanter la philosophie de ceux ci la
technologie de cela la science 2 on
occulte toujours la dimension
spirituelle de tous les peuples qui nous
ont précédés aussi tu vois aussi grand
soit-il les égyptiens ont fait des
prouesses architecturales qu'on voit là
aujourd'hui encore une fois c'est très
tabou et on peut pas vraiment savoir
mais tous en fête ont développé un hymne
tous se sont connectés à cette sphère
imaginaire inaccessible tu vois et nous
non nous la laïcité nous a dit bon je
dis pas que le vatican et son emprise
sur le sujet sur sur les gens pendant
des siècles enfin voilà ce qu'on lançait
été très castratrice et tous je dis pas
que c'était de bonne méthode mais le
fait est que au moins ça permettait de
créer au moins un décor de base c'est à
dire que tu avais accès au moins une
représentation mentale après libre à toi
d'aller chercher le deuxième et le
troisième degré de lecture tu vois mais
tous égaux devant dieu au moins tu vois
ça mettait le paysan au même rang que le
roi c'était une tentative d'équilibrer
les choses tu vois c'est pas pour bien
sûr si tu leur store sous le glaive bat
là-bas je pense que c'est des recrues de
poésie tu vois qu'ils soient d'origine
divine de révélations je sais pas mais
après comme on en parlait si
l'inspiration extérieur qu'est-ce-qui
divin qui est ce qu'il n'est pas et tu
vois donc que ce soit dans le peut-être
que c'est juste des livres de poésie qui
tentait de donner des bases communes un
peu pour dire bon voila moi je propose
cette version là tu vois évoluer dans ce
cadre là tu vois et ça paraît un peu
s'il ya beaucoup de choses qui se
recoupent même toit selon les
civilisations les spiritualités donc il
ya très certainement une souche commune
tu as enfin en tout cas cette lutte
entre les forces on va dire du bien et
du mal pour schématiser ces dualités au
sein de l'homme elle a un petit peu je
pense partout faudra jongler avec alors
est-ce que ça symbolise nos pulsions
animales nos pulsions violentes ce qu'il
faut réfréner mais en tout cas ouais moi
ce que j'aime en fait c'est les gens
avec des valeurs après ils peuvent être
athée ils peuvent se définir comme ils
veulent en fait c est que des adjectifs
qui au final vont diviser plus qu'autre
chose tu vois moi je regarde des gens
avec lesquels je partage les systèmes de
valeur en termes de chez pas moins de
2,2 ou même d'hospitalité de fâcher
pâtes et des valeurs qui sont ces même
pas de l'éthique 6 il eut cessé de la
bourse et du bon sens et de la cud et
bonnes manières enfin voilà comme tout
le monde j'aime bien les gens gentils
respectueux courtois polis tu vois enfin
version très primaire pour le coup mais
après peu importe en fait si tu vois pas
ce qu'il ya des gens qui sont religieux
et qui n'ont pas compris et ça se voit
tu vois
sont pas respectueux avec leur entourage
ils sont très borné tu as enfin et puis
tant la doute qu'ils sont très ouverts
qu'ils sont capables d'échanger en paix
de tout avec n'importe qui parce qu'ils
sont en paix avec eux-mêmes donc ils ont
rien avant disons tu vois donc on peut
pas faire de généralités que je pense
que les chacun responsable de sa petite
barque you et si les gens se rate bon
bah tant pis tu vois servez vous de cet
échec pour en tirer un retour intérêts
tu vois un feedback pour vous améliorer
tu vois mes groupes je pense pas qu'on
va vieillir pour vivre mal en fait quoi
ce serait triste
qu'est ce que tu penses de la mort
l'âme or comme le métal ou la mort à
l'extérieur peut-être je sais pas et tu
vas donc d oise on pourrait voir ça et
tu vois
mais tu peux aussi voir qui est bas
voilà enfin
je crois que c'est dur instyle un souci
qui faisaient ça en fait fort et morts
forcé de mocky des rassembleurs quatre
éléments parce qu'ils sont présumés feu
eau air terre tuant morte enlève le feu
tu vas encore et je le remplace par m la
matrice en fait que parce que c'était la
forme des femmes qui accouchent tu vois
et tous les enfants dans le monde le
premier son qui disent hey mama donc
pour sec le mama et universel en fait et
en français au moyen-age on le disait à
feu mon oncle tu as donc on associer le
feu à la bordeaux moi je pense que la
mort ces bassins
trépassé en fait ça va il ya peut-être
trois éléments qui passe de l'autre côté
on dit et en fait on nous a toujours dit
pour nous rabaisser peut-être ou du
moins dans le dogme et du vatican tu es
poussière tu retourneras à la poussière
mais en effet 80% d'eau donc à un moment
ou un autre on va s'évaporer va
retourner à tout le du monde tu vois
donc c'est un peu rassurant de se dire
que voilà il ya 80% de notre être qu'il
va quand même retourné perpétré ce cycle
est dans le dans la mythologie
égyptienne rencontre le chaos primordial
qu'un océan à l'autre même nous on vient
d eau dont les continents l'eau non
aucun on vient d eau on vient des eaux
de notre mère donc pour les
accouchements dans l'eau sont justement
beaucoup moins m acquise en avant qu on
s y perd les eaux pourquoi parce qu'on
est conçu dandenault en fait
naturellement tu as donc vient ccc l'eau
c'est la source de toute vie qu'on nous
dit que l'os est la source de tout c'est
vraiment au propre et au figuré tout et
pour le coup du coup donc la mort
qu'est-ce qui se passe ben moi je pense
que la mort toutes les questions tu as
là on philosophe et puis bon il ya
toujours une partie des réponses qui
nous sont accessibles parce qu'au final
on saura jamais il peut spéculer on peut
s'enrichir on peut se persuader avec nos
expériences aussi créer des chemins on
peut tracer des chemins qui dans
certaines circonstances peuvent prendre
sens tout à coup et tout à l'heure on a
parlé
de la vertu du langage le fait que
parfois en verbalisant les choses eh ben
on les révèle on les fait sortir de nous
défendre les guesh des fois aussi mais
ça risque à prendre peut-être que les
chemins un peu abstrait spéculatives
contre haas par les discussions comme on
est en train d'en avoir peuvent aussi
créer un petit sillon qui un jour
prendra sens dans une circonstance
particulière quand plate on parle de la
réminiscence il le fait d'un point de
vue philosophique et pourtant il exprime
quelque chose de très mystique à savoir
qu'on vient sur terre en oubliant tout
ce qu'on a vu lorsqu'on était dans la
région d âme une âme éternelle et que
l'incarnation la venue sur terre est un
oubli dont on doit se retrouver dans
l'argent je crois que les boues dc 10 1
dans le cursus de réincarnation une âme
en fait elle a accès à toute sa vie aux
trois temps voilà et c'est à l avance
tout ce qu'elle va vivre dans cette vie
tu vois elle y va mais passe par la
phase de l'oubli parce que pour aborder
de manière émotive
cette nouvelle vie comme une page
blanche elle obligée de passer par la
phase de l'oubli tu vois de quoi ça peut
se rejoindre qui va encore une fois je
te dis à beaucoup de passerelles entre
eux lorient l'occident même la
mythologie scandinave
fatwa l'aider même l'été je connais pas
après l'été du risque puisque ça mais je
suis persuadé que si on cherche on
trouvera les mêmes principes actifs et
la même vision métaphysique au magic au
philosophico poético du monde grosso
modo mais les buts c'est quoi à la fin
c'est juste que tu veux et tu veux être
bien en fait je pense que c'est ça le
but pour même inutile que la philosophie
en fait les questions qu'on se pose
elles sont intéressantes uniquement si
la réponse va améliorer notre quotidien
sinon ça sert à rien en fait c'est de la
branlette studio c'est comme se poser la
question est ce que la réalité existe
vraiment si la réponse est non ça
changera pas le fait que tu vas qu'on te
comporter comme si elle existait
vraiment finalement ça
voilà il ya un moment c'est trop
justement je pense que la philosophie
c'est bien mais la vie c'est pas qu'un
bureau d'études ya aussi une partie
chantier donc c'est toujours bien
d'aller confronté justement ces idées
soient ses intuitions au monde réel si
non en fait on est juste tout seul dans
sa tête et se trouve fascinant fait tuer
d'après toi qu'est ce qu'il donne du
sens à ce qu'on fait
ban ou
finale d'où un sens c'est quoi c'est une
direction
bah voila tu as un directeur ans c'est
quelqu'un qui donne la direction nous on
va faire comme ça on va aller par là
dessus au final je me suis beaucoup
c'est qu'il quel sens on quel sens à la
vie bat juste lui qu'on va lui donner en
faites quoi doxa doute choisir mais
voilà si tu choisis de partir au nord
qui renonce au sud c'est tout donc faut
juste être capable de se mettre en
chemin ou en cheminement est d'être
capable de renoncer à tout ce qui va
être à l'opposé quoi
avoir des enfants ça donne du sens
à ces thèmes de l'amour celle de l'amour
un sens non parce qu'il tue peut pas
élever des enfants avec la pression de
ta propre vie c'est à dire que tu vis
pas pour eux tu vis est sensé pour vivre
pour toi quand même c'est à dire que si
tu places tout les espoirs sur tes
enfants qui sont pas à la hauteur de tes
attentes bah quoi en fait tu as donc non
et puis même c'est la phrase j'ai tout
fait pour toi tu vois ce que je veux
dire et puis ses parents qui mettent une
pression sur les enfants c'est vous dire
à ses enfants un papa il voulait être
footballeur mais il a arrêté parce
qu'ils étaient on sait à quoi tu es en
train de dire que j'ai gâché ta life
chose que je veux dire donc non non non
non je pense que ça c'est le
c'est l'expérience ultime tu vois ce que
je vais dire en termes d'amour
d'enrichissement de deux de ses tribuns
c'est instinctif c'est génétique c'est
tu vois c'est là pour et je pense qu'il
faut la vivre au mieux cette expérience
que dans ce spectacle c'est à tes
enfants
non je pense pas
non
non c'est moi mon spectacle ouais c'est
moi c'est pas une excroissance parce que
je pense que ça fonctionne qu'avec moi
mon enfant un moment il est autonome tu
vois enfin
le spectacle non peut pas l'être tu vois
si il peut vivre sur internet sur des
vidéos peut-être tu vois mais
non mais on peut passer un spectacle
s'est figé c'est comme ça ça bougera
plus tu as enfin même si d'une
représentation à l'autre bien sûr c'est
jamais la même chose si tu as aimé sap a
les capacités d'interaction non non
c'est pas une bonne image concerts
spectacles c'est pas un enfant jorat
c'est mon bébé non non c'est nul que je
pense que même tous ceux qui ont des
enfants ils
sont censés enfin voila je pense que
personne ne peut dire ce qu si tu as des
enfants tu peux pas comparer ton travail
at-on enfants tiens je pense pas
on va terminer alors dans l'actualité
alors que je te dis je règle mon
spectacle sa mère la grosse plume je
vais commencer à l'euro des courants
mais logiquement si tout se passe bien
voilà j'ai aussi un rdpc titres avec mon
petit frère bon c'est pas comment on va
le sortir avec qui etc
voila j'aimerais bien tourner la saison
2 de la websérie et puis j'ai d'autres
projets pro après b qui concerne pas la
face est public pour le coup comme et
voilà où allah dans l'immédiat déjà sa
messe de quoi m'occuper hockey un
message à transmettre à ceux qui nous
écoutent
non
ok chacun pour soi et dieu pour tous non
je sais pas un prénom nom venait ici
venez me voir en spectacle ça peut être
je sais pas je pense que ça va être bien
il y aura de la musique un décor cette
fois ci je fais un petit truc j'ai envie
plus dans le passé comme une troupe une
petite troupe de théâtre sur ce que je
veux dire donc voilà en tout cas je fais
quelque chose qui n'existe pas vraiment
donc tu vois
voilà cet arrêté merci à toi ça c'est à
plaisir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]